[Applaudissements]
au delà de la pratique sportive et de
l'approfondissement de ces pratiques
sportives
on propose des cours de théorie
notamment pour aborder d'autres champs
disciplinaires comme le les sciences
humaines les humanités donc on peut
proposer
bien sûr tout ce qui est relatif à la
physiologie de l'effort tout pour le
lien qui existe entre la théorie et la
pratique des activités physiques et
sportives
c'est destiné à tous les élèves à
l'issue de la seconde qui le souhaitent
il n'est pas nécessaire par exemple
d'avoir suivi l'option au ps en seconde
pour aller et demandé cette spécialité
comme ça se comporte comme tous les
autres spécialités en fin de seconde
c'est à dire que on propose l'élève doit
choisir trois spécialités en première et
on pourrait en terminale il n'en choisit
que deux mille ans il peut en retirer
une en fin de seconde les tous les
élèves peuvent choisir cette spécialité
parmi les trois qui doivent choisir en
première
l'idée c'est de rentrer de toute façon
dans le de pouvoir vivre en quelque
sorte avec cette spécialité aussi bien
en première et en terminale
si l'élève le choisit et bien entendu
dans le cadre de cette réforme ont un
rapport directement avec parcours sup
puisque les élèves qui choisiraient
cette spécialité aurait un attrait
particulier avec tous les métiers qu'ils
aient un rapport avec le corps et donc
on espère que l'algorithme de parcours
sud va pouvoir s'y intégrer